you said on the album that you signed
the deal when you lost your ambition
yeah
yeah it wasn't like i signed a deal when
i lost my ambition but you were you when
you signed the deal maybe you were in a
tough place as far as when i signed a
deal i was in a great i was in a great
place like when i when i made the
decision i was gonna sign
but um no where that line came from was
just what was happening in my life and
basically you got to like listen to the
the album as a whole to like understand
it but it wasn't it was it had nothing
to do with my career like
the last two years have just been like
crazy for me like
i've grown up a lot a lot has happened
you know like the beginning
a lot of people know me from [ __ ] i did
as like a teenager so
just like like turning 20 and like the
last two years for real i just been like
crazy so you're not even 21 yet no i'm
23 now
wait what the [ __ ] i'm like
so
what that line is about is just like
i was really for real just like dealing
with
the catalyst of it was like my first
breakup that i've ever like been through
um and that just like
it showed me a lot about myself because
it was like the first time like
i just i don't know i was like really by
myself
and i learned a lot about myself
and um
it just
it just woke up all these parts of me
that i haven't seen since i was like
real young
so at that time like it was just weird
how so many things were happening at the
same time it was like this my first
relationship ended i got a crib i got a
whip i got the deal but i had no one to
like really
share with you so it was like a lotta
and then [ __ ] gone with my mom and then
my sister and it was like i kept getting
tested
and then i just i just really like it
was a journey bro but
it turned out amazing because like i
just feel like
i feel like i'm not living through
my career really anymore because when i
was younger
you know a lot of people know me when i
was like a teenager i'm like you're
trying to hitting every cipher going
crazy rapidly
trying to improve myself like i'm just
trying to make it i forget what tour i
what what tour were you on early on um
bobson i saw yep yep yeah i was on just
like
just trying to prove myself just trying
to make it
um
and it was honest at the time but
um
like now it's just not about it's just
not about like proving anymore like i
don't really feel like i have anything
to prove and whether people like know it
or not i'm not here
because
of how i can spit like people might not
know that but i'm here because of like
the way i write and my perspective and
and the life i've lived
and now it's just feels like everything
at this point is like synchronizing like
i really feel i'd really feel me again
like i don't feel like i'm living
through my career my last project i know
i'm written but go do your thing bro my
last project
you know is is i feel this way because
of my career this girl looks at me
because of my career it's literally
called between somewhere it's like i'm
between fame and a normal person it's
like i'm
all this is because
of my career and then with this one it's
just like bro i feel this way because
i'm me
this people
this person looks at me because i'm me
like i really feel me now